foreign
[Music]
welcome to question time tonight we are
in Norwich on tonight's panel Penny
Morton the government's trade Minister
formerly International Development
secretary and briefly defense secretary
on the Theresa May labors Shadow
Northern Ireland secretary before
entering politics he worked in Eastern
Europe and the Balkans helping young
people whose lives have been disrupted
by War Peter Kyle Kasson Oswald first
elected as an MP in 2015 overturning a
labor stronghold since 2020 Deputy
leader of the s p at Westminster Bridget
Kendall journalist and master of Peter
house at Cambridge University Moscow
corresponded for the BBC in the early
90s during the gorba 12 years and
Russian British commentator and comedian
host of the YouTube show trigonometry
Constantine kissing
[Music]
hi um Putin has not been deterred by the
sanctions so far what else can be done
other than a war that nobody's got an
appetite for
Constantine
um there's a few things I'd say before I
answer the question the first is I've
lived in this country since 1995. I'm
proud to be British I've also been proud
to be Russian Russia is a country who's
produced some of the greatest works of
literature music all sorts of things of
that nature but I'm afraid as I sit here
tonight I feel nothing but shame for my
country and for what it's doing
um it's a very difficult moment for many
people I have family in Ukraine who are
now being bombarded who are fleeing for
their lives and when I speak to them one
of the things they say to me is how
grateful they are to people in Britain
for everything that you're doing and for
the moral support that your country is
providing so thank you on behalf of
everybody there
um as for the serious business of what
we're talking about I'm afraid everyone
on the panel is refusing to give you an
honest answer because the truth is
there's nothing we can do NATO cannot
get involved in this because that would
start World War III uh which would lead
to the annihilation of all of us uh NATO
cannot provide any more support than
what we're already doing of course we
can keep supplying ammunition and
weapons and so on which we will do I'm
sure but this is I'm afraid to fight the
ukrainians have to win the only way this
conflict ends is at the negotiating
table the only way for us to get to the
negotiating table is for ukrainians to
put up a fight that is strong enough
that Putin wants to come to the
negotiating table and at that point
there are ways to make sure that
everybody wins at that negotia education
because and this is what I've been
warning people in the west about well of
course I understand the rhetoric about
Vladimir Putin and Russia we don't want
to back him into a corner because this
is existential at this point for him he
knows there's no way back there's no way
back into the International Community
there's no way back for Russia to be
welcomed and if that is the case we're
leading uh him into a very potentially
dark past so we've got to be careful at
the end of the day this will end in the
negotiation I know that's unpleasant for
people to hear and I'm not talking about
appeasement of any kind we have to make
it clear uh what the consequences will
be if he goes any further but I'm afraid
at this point we can provide support to
Ukraine but they are going to have to
win this fight themselves and this idea
Constantine that Bridget's hinting at in
terms of not everyone comfortable with
what Putin is doing perhaps into upper
echelons there is this quiet there's
there's a I sort of hope that
that the the senior people in in Moscow
might just manage to either overthrow
him or somehow diverting
no completely false hope it's not going
to happen he has complete control over
the country he's been in power since
1999 I often tell people you've got to
understand Vladimir Putin when he came
first came to power we worried about the
millennium bug so he's had plenty of
time to get the country under his
control none of that is going to happen
uh we have to deal with the real politic
of this and the real politic of this is
ukrainians are going to have to put up a
fight they're going to have to get to
the negotiating table and then at that
point they're going to have to give away
things they don't care about which is
Crimea and the two Eastern regions
nobody in Ukraine expects to get those
back anyway and we in the west are going
to have to put not promises but actual
things in place that are going to ensure
Ukraine's long-term security so that
country cannot be invaded again more
pieces cannot be bitten off it and that
may in the end involve some kind of
peacekeeping force on that board I'm
afraid okay there's a lot of hands on so
the other thing is we've heard is we
need to send the message to the people
in Russia that blah blah blah people in
Russia don't watch BBC question time I'm
afraid uh they've watched Russian
national television that's how most
Russians get their news they're going to
be continuing to get fed uh State
propaganda as they have been for the
last few weeks I've been monitoring it
I'm afraid uh what the people in Russia
being told is that there's a genocide
being committed in Ukraine that NATO is
about to invade that NATO is getting
ready to position missiles to strike
against the heart of Russia and no
message we send here is going to change
that this is about the situation on the
ground in Ukraine that has to be dealt
with it's nothing to do with what we say
here on the spot so do you think in
terms of in terms of oligarch for
example and sanctions against them or
not being sent back he's been demanding
this for years he's wanted to repatriate
the money and to get them back into
Russia this isn't going to change
anything
Bridget I think we may well start to see
some figures who sat on the fence and
they've sort of moved their family to
Britain and quite a lot of their
personal wealth and bought nice houses
in weybridge
but they've still done business in
Russia and gone along to those big
Kremlin meetings with Mr Putin has
happened recently they're going to have
to make a choice I mean some of them are
now on the sanctions list
but I think they're going to be more
people who um
might decide to come out and say how
dismayed they are and outraged at what
their government's doing as you just did
Constantine and I know you're a British
citizen but there are others for whom
it'll be a bigger deal and will that
make any difference I think it will make
a difference and there I disagree with
you Constantine I think that there are a
lot of Russians older Russians who do
watch State television but a lot of
younger Russians who don't I remember
once doing a
um a program in Petersburg asking people
if they thought they lived in a
democracy and a young man in the
audience said when I watch State
television no I don't I think I live in
an authoritarian state but when I go on
the internet I feel I live in a
democracy sadly Mr Putin is trying to
limit that access but he won't be able
to we live in a social media age and
messages will get through and when
people don't think what they're hearing
on the state media quite adds up they
will look for other sources of
information and you know how people will
talk to each each other they'll swap
notes of course when you get a level of
fear where people are even scared to
talk to each other as it happened at
some points in the Soviet era then it's
very difficult to spread those messages
but I I still feel that there's a lot of
things that can be done by Russians
inside Russia or even Russians outside
Russia to put pressure and to to call
out to call out this regime and a lot of
people with big audiences in Russia
actors comedians Etc have been doing
this and and so there is a generational
split but my point was the broader
public in Russia 65 to 70 support what's
happening and the reason they support
what's happening is what they're being
told on their television screen okay let
me hear a couple points where I move on
yes I think with refugees and remember
some of my family members will be in
this position uh those who are going to
be unsafe in neighboring countries those
who have family links perhaps with the
UK I absolutely I think should be
allowed to come but I think in terms of
the number of people who are going to be
fleeing War the best place to provide
support for them is near near the border
of Ukraine in Poland and the Polish
people have been incredibly generous and
we can be generous to provide fine
finance and other things in place to
support people locally because not every
Ukrainian wants to come to the UK quite
a lot of them would love to come back to
Ukraine once this is hopefully over so I
think we've got to have a calibrated
response just saying we must throw the
borders open to anyone who wants to come
isn't going to solve the problem and by
the way given that we've had 20 years of
very large levels of immigration into
this country you will create problems
domestically it will disrupt our the
fabric of our society as you know people
have made that point so I think we've
got to make sure that we provide
everything we possibly can to people who
need it but that does not necessarily
have to be done by bringing people here
in huge numbers there's way to deal with
this locally and that will be better for
the people who we're talking about can I
see I
if pushed do you think Putin will use
nuclear weapons well let's have a quick
run around the panel on this Constantine
100
do you think we've pushed yeah if he
feels that his life is on the line of
course you're using nuclear weapons
since if you if he felt the war in
Ukraine was not going his way do you
think he and NATO got involved yeah
Bridget I mean you've you've got the
advantage of having met the man who's
around the rest of us have
well I'm not sure I'm not sure the man I
met which was um 2001 2006. well you
know a while ago it's quite the man that
is in charge now because I never thought
he'd do which he he's done in the last
two weeks I thought he was more rational
than that so that's not very encouraging
is it if he's not very rational then
maybe he would press the button but I
think that there would be people around
him who would think
he's crazy we've got to stop him because
I think there are a lot of people in
Russia who are Russian I know
Constantine doesn't agree with me he
thinks he's got enough
um control that he would be allowed to
do something quite as mad as that no I
do agree with you I think there would be
people who may try to stop him whether
they're successful or not is a different
question but you will know with your
time in Russia that human life has a
very different value in Russia than it
does in the west I'm afraid and so the
rationale for making these decisions is
different and what do you mean by that
Russian I mean the Russian attitude to
human life is that it's less valuable
individual is less sacrosanct if you
look at
you know the history of Russia
um I was actually interviewing a his
British historian about this today and
he made the point that if you go to the
memorial to Soviet soldiers in Berlin uh
these are people who who defeat the
Nazis and these great Heroes they're
buried in Mass Graves they didn't even
have the Dignity of being buried in
their own grave that is the attitude
historically that's how it's always been
and this is one of the things I'm afraid
people in the west really don't
understand and I think you probably do a
little bit is people in that part of the
world have a very different moral
framework for making these decisions so
you but use it but but
um using nuclear weapons is also a
self-destruct button isn't it because it
doesn't stop there but the question was
if pushed
yes but if you what you're saying is
that leaders in Russia have been
Cavalier with human life with their foot
soldiers I agree in history that's
happened but if they're thinking about
their own Survival
um to use a nuclear weapon is not a very
good strategy to survive that's where
you have to worry is irrational now or
not quite
the men they don't agree
so Cassie you hear Penny saying the
nuclear deterrent Works obviously esnp
in Independence Scotland would not have
the nuclear deterrent absolutely no and
you know you can imagine people who live
where I live which is just down the road
from the fast lane nuclear base or
listening to that and thinking that that
doesn't sound terribly good
um I do think Putin is saber-rattling
but I think that you know certainly if
from my point of view it really
underlines why nuclear weapons have no
place and certainly down my road and not
down your road there's no place for
nuclear weapons but if we had nuclear
weapons in Scotland didn't and
independent Scotland didn't an
independence
would you feel safer or less safe
now yeah I'm sure that we would feel at
least as safe because of course he's
seeing them now and we do have these
nuclear weapons in the UK it's you know
it's a really serious Point actually you
know and I I appreciate people that have
different views here but I think it's a
valid question to ask I I do think that
there are people around him who would
not
um you know be averse to stepping in but
um you know the the prospect of any
country having weapons of mass
destruction is perhaps one that we
should reflect on and think again about
um certainly in in Scotland that there
is a a significant body of support for
us not to have nuclear weapons both
within our parliament in Scotland and in
Civic Society too and I can only see uh
that that feeling growing even though
he's happy for me to decide whether the
people of Scotland have a nuclear weapon
but uh it's for the people of Scotland
but the idea that in a world where we
have nuclear weapons that we would try
and put the toothpaste back in the tube
where it's not going to go is absolutely
asinine and the idea that we would stop
being able to defend ourselves by having
a deterrent in a world where people like
Xi Jinping and Vladimir Putin have
nuclear weapons is completely absurd
it's absurd of we have to have a
deterrent otherwise where would Vladimir
put Vladimir Putin's troops be today
the only reason the only reason they are
still in Ukraine and not in Poland is
that we have nuclear weapons it's as
simple as that and there is also simple
there's another Point here and Ukraine
is one of the very few countries in the
world that gave up its nuclear yes
weapons yes
um
to whim because it's signed a 1994
Budapest memorandum on the behalf of the
West yeah all right we promised Britain
America
protect them protect their boundaries
protect their sovereignty if he gave up
its nuclear weapons it did because
Russia promised as well and Russia a
bigger pardon yeah he gave it all up and
what have we done we've sold them down
the river
this is why the the point I made at the
very beginning is very important however
the situation ends up being resolved the
Ukrainian nation has to have not
guarantees not a contract not worth the
Papers written on but actual protection
from further aggression and we are going
to have to have a very difficult
conversation about what that looks like
as a country and us I think NATO and the
United States in particular because if
we don't this will carry on